[Music]
all right I really think you guys are
for real gonna like this one it's pretty
funny
especially Bart because this takes place
in Taiwan oh you know Taiwanese politics
we all know they love to resort to fist
fighting you crazy yeah but this one is
not fist fighting oh this one it's a
taipei city councillor he lost a bet he
actually like followed through with what
he said he was gonna be doing so he is
actually a youtuber as well he found
what he founded the can't stop this
party in May and so he had claimed that
no more than 400,000 people will turn
out for the recall vote on a certain
mayor and and so it actually oh so he
said that for every 10,000 votes above
his bet that he would smash a pair of
chopsticks with his ass so he lost the
bet hold on okay so he lost the bet and
he broke 53 chopsticks with his ass and
he filmed it and posted on YouTube and
we're gonna watch it it's a
councilmember yes is this porn no you do
that and he looks kind of smart this is
what are you doing it cuz he has glasses
up what up what looks like David so used
to see like true
David's Instagram here we go haha
no he's like clenching his ass like it's
in between like his underwear like a
needle through a thong and then Oh max
are you gonna strong us start off with
like one chocolate at a time then you
went up to two and then three and then
up to like five at one point it's gotta
be like 25 pounds of pressure right
there and then the citizens of this city
are like really proud of ya they're
really happy that she actually felt it
followed through because there I was
just rooting for him I was like come on
man you got it I like all these grown
men are just starting at is a period of
time like after he votes women or like
the election whatever and cuz each
chopstick it represents 10,000 votes
over 400,000 right so that's so I turned
out to be nine hundred and thirty nine
thousand and ninety votes to and so that
int that translated to fifty three point
nine oh nine chopsticks so you should
have done fifty for you so is saying two
of my head up why can't our politics be
this fun
Mitch McConnell doing great strength in
the white but mm-hmm
get a strong but yeah yeah tight you
know what city this is typing I would
trust my politicians if they did [ __ ]
like that and they weren't afraid to be
embarrassed and then to like this by
yeah I think I've ever seen like
Taiwanese politics so it looks like you
know and they're meeting in like a
pretty formal place looking like a
congress and then they start yelling and
then they start throwing pencils and
paper and then they'll hop over like
chair that chairs no hot ball and they
just start fighting just straight square
a missus sanctioned no they're not
allowed to
they just do it just do it and it's
almost like like quite an endo they'll
split apart and it's almost like the
Democrats and the Republicans like don't
lock the doors I'd not let them come in
and they'll like build a barricade with
the desks and the chairs then they're
like they have a full-on war dude the
only reason why I noticed about
Taiwanese politics is because uh you
know Canada hat Mike Myers that one with
the babysitter she turns on the TV and
then there's just like a whole bunch of
like Asian people fighting each other
and then the kids look at each other
those Taiwanese Parliament and then they
leave and I'm like this happens I Wow
look what happened to Mike Myers he's
around he was just in that uh oh yeah
the Queen was queen before that I
haven't seen him in years
yeah he was killing everyone oh yeah
he's a brave Love Guru destroyed his
career it was Kanye what member
conn-young
George was doesn't care about black
people Mike Meyers was the funniest
thing he ever did it was the honest
reaction to Kanye he's like oh [ __ ] I
was watching that real-time and I was
like oh oh yeah Treena telethon uh-huh
oh it's great Mike Meyers is just like
and then they cut the Chris Tucker he's
a man but yet Shrek in Austin Powers
like coming out at the same time yeah oh
yeah you know he has [ __ ] you money like
maybe he's like I'm on vacation he also
did the Cat in the Hat I don't know
that's my favorite movie is it really no
I mean not really what did you do enjoy
the reason why I label that as my
favorite movies because that's the one
movie I can literally quote from like
beginning to end I could tell you every
lie how did you get into watching that
so many times we had the DVD and I was
bored oh no I watched it a lot you're
like no no
I really like 14 now I'm questioning a
little bit your opinion because you said
earlier that song the Hedgehog sucks
calf said to his wife like that his kids
like it you like the cat in the hat'
movie that nobody I've ever met I love
this is 14 year old tip that loves it
ok Belgic to museums do a nas and
watching Kaveri neither watched it
because you want a pass back at home for
sure in front of my mom your mom didn't
do like why do you have so many balloons
no you did not uh no so the NAS was kind
of like only at the parties but the
thing that they did find out was me
[ __ ] huffing the air fresheners it
was just the actual spray as long as it
doesn't taste bad like tequila okay my
friend I'm not proud of this at all
I'm very issue but tell us why it was so
fun no but I actually did have a
preference of air fresheners because I
did have different flavors like doing
really our trash I'm actually very she
feels like a Baskin Robbins 31 flavors
same air which I do miss Air Wick it was
I don't miss it ashamed of myself over
this scent was it lavender it was it was
the teal one I forgot like rain for or
something alright so look that one up
kids don't do it and also don't even try
because they've changed the way they
make their bottles so you can't even do
it it's on people do it if you even if
you wanted to can't even do it
do you guys would be able to make
blowtorches before it doesn't work
anymore really
I tried it was my mouth comes out and
that's what it doesn't it won't when I
was a kid that was that child yes my
son's I don't know why but I tried I was
trying I was like look guys fire and
then it didn't work he just kept blowing
out the pellet stove you know that
like cringe now it's nowhere I'm gonna
try it no like that the fumes that come
out so like it would be like you put a
towel over it and the fumes is what you
would inhale your teeth you guys how to
do them not because you can't anymore
don't even try cuz you can't what
they're all trying I wanted to smoke a
ball but you can't but Toto try but if
you wanted to make sure that you get the
seeds out for a headache but you don't
want to don't do it but in there bad but
don't do it don't do it really bad I
regret this part of my life but then
make sure that like when you be back in
glowing the guy in there yeah he lives
on the third house okay so go to that
streets Knox green up it's probably not
the same password anymore but it but it
was you want to try Bagga bond we worked
when I was a kid telling you it was so
bad at one point this is how my mom
found out I was doing this because I so
stupid yet colors all over chips I
actually saved all the empty cans and I
had a collection and I grew the
collection up to 80 can't holy sheets
age i refresh it it was a dollar that's
a looking liquor so your mom comes in
she sees all this [ __ ] and then you're
like it smells pretty good in here look
how do you how do you get away from that
I was so dumb or young she'd love she
needed a lot of love ever tried getting
a Arabic brand deal now and you can say
like as a kid you could train your kids
amazing me like air fresheners of Venice
I'm gonna smoke those it's good your
cringe and their friends are not good
that's what is that's not worse they're
like I don't do drugs I eat this couch
though I saw one last week this is this
lady was eating her cat's hair oh look
at her cat I'm gonna office have office
oh yeah but she was eating it she licked
her cat then she ate it it was the worst
I think if my kid was eating my couch I
mean I can't just try cigarettes as well
your respectable drug bait don't lick
the cat you freakin weirdo
glass or something no place that's part
of the cache again it's pretty bad I do
not I mean yeah anyway so back to this
guy this city councillor so what I said
previously was that he had actually
gotten some splinters between his butt
cheeks because of the chopsticks break
that's a lot and have to break with your
ass even threes a lot do it for the
votes no this is what he said he liked
people were commenting and they said
doing what you promised that's what I
call a real politician and why Joe
exotic got votes yeah because he were
like that's all it takes for people like
do what you promised no like yeah man
I'll vote for that guy
mmm if Joe's I ran now he'd get way more
that's how sad he might win medical
system is is that we've been lied to we
expect to be lied to here just someone
sit doing the same do what they say the
room is like wow well you said you're
gonna bust some chop stick with your
butt and you are man of your word you
did it you got my it's like the dating
scene right now some girls are like he
was nice yes oh he was just people
aren't yeah I'm ready to send them a
meth-addicted mullet man to water I'm
ready I mean what else like I mean yeah
how else do we how crazy or does it get
exactly like where do we go from here
I'm ready for a tiger to be vice
president
Joe exotic and Tony the Tiger
[Music]
[Music]